i just woke up thinking about going home
with you and got very excited about
christmas
i get to go meet the people that made my
favorite person i'll always take
december
abby you and harper have a perfect
relationship she is
my person and i really want everyone to
know that i want to marry her
what are you doing on your phone i left
a gentleman alone in my apartment so i'm
tracking him to make sure he leaves
you're tracking him
yeah i track everybody if the nsa can do
it so can i
[Music]
i'm so excited i can't believe i'm
finally going to meet everyone there's
something that we should talk about
hi i didn't tell my parents i'm gay so
who do they think i am this is harper's
orphan friend abby yes of course they're
there
you're so brave you don't need to be
i cannot believe i've got all my
daughters under one roof
so her parents believe their straight
daughter brought home her lesbian friend
for christmas not exactly they also
think that i'm straight
have they ever met a lesbian this is why
i avoid christmas
it brings out the worst in everything
i've always skated circles around you
i love it when they do this you're such
a cheater makes it so fun
just be yourself but don't lie you're a
very bad liar riley
harper this is abby abby is my orphan
roommate we i am an orphan but we live
together
as friends um like acquaintance yeah
i can relate to being in love with
somebody that is too afraid to show the
world who they are
what are you doing in the closet
i'm here to rescue you are you the
ex-boyfriend yes
i am very sexually attracted to her
a female i nailed that and she is
fabulous
[Music]
i am scared that if i tell them who i
really am i will lose them do you know
how painful it's been to watch the
person that i love
hide me i am not hiding you i am hiding
me
everybody's story is different just
because harper isn't ready
doesn't mean she doesn't love you
[Music]
abby honey are you okay good morning
i'm sorry about all this mess morning
kids
morning honey i'm heading to the office
have a good day you know i will
you